je crois qu'on va bien s'amuser
bonne soirée à toi je suis content de
les avoir parce que ils sont
sympathiques un os aux petits pots delà
de la haute montage sans sympathie puis
la halle à fond à fond contre les braves
aller bravo comme tout tu fous toi on va
se fendre la gueule
il nous dit charles qu'est ce que je
sais bien c'est tout quoi que ça m'amuse
ma possible mon failli nous ils nous ont
invités trois fois on peut prendre
refusé comme ça pendant des c'est la
corvée celles apportées
non cela veut dire alors qu'ils sont ils
sont très sains mais ils sont chaque
fois on pouvait passer ce premier tour
j'arrive à ranger ben va ouvrir nom de
dieu
le pont est allé on s'assoit à la swapo
deux messieurs c'est la bonne franquette
entre copains oui bah va chercher le
pastaga six absents du paju net
j'aimerais mieux quelque chose au pastis
voyez quelque chose mais le pastis du
pastaga et puis vient de chez son père
mais vas-y aux seniors
son père vous avez vous demandé vélib
dans les vosges à des vosges et renaud
dély sceptiques ou non de dieu ne faudra
pas de ma mère et tu sais on pourrait
sans mettre dedans j'y repense j'ai
repensé à ces vacances de quesques on
s'est marré en fait je hais je le
rejoignais exit pin-up là sur les sauts
à skis noter que je le regardais pas ses
salariés testino d'ericsson baila bellay
qui pendaient des dommages mais si je me
souvenais que s'ils s'attendaient
vraiment beaucoup
alors dites moi roger le jour je ne
montais sur chameau alors déjà l'image
était au redoutable
oui alors malheureux le plus drôle le
plus drôle c'est elle était quand même
la tête de la tête de la tête de l'île
avec sa lampe de poche et ça passe à
epinay parler sous la fayolle
mais je me souviens c'était comme ça
ces deux fesses deux énormes porter ces
choix pour ridiculiser moi ça ne nous
convient pas bougé pour mettre
l'ambiance et les magasins nous sommes
très mal l'ambiance était plutôt calme
l'ambiance pour nous c'est terminé
et oui maintenant je sois là il son
travail soit et je me souviens tu as tu
es dans la tête en l'aérophagie quoi
spatiale l'aérospatiale et oui les
avions d'autres bordels et les fusées
pour tous on s'occupe surtout de du
programme ariane enfin maintenant
qu'elle décolle on sur les terres on ne
veut la télé l'autre à la base et les
brûler à ariane tu dira bonjour je
dirais la fusée ariane
non mais non enfin tous les soirs on se
fout on se fout la gueule vous faites
exactement dans cette usine
et bien c'est à dire que je dirige une
unité de recherche du programme à 11 13
mai vous avez passé laisser happer alors
pour ça
non c'est comme ça disons que j'ai pas
arrêté mon professeur agrégé à la vente
physique des mets toi paris vite allée
des professeurs un physique de métaux à
part huit locaux et ensuite pour sa
maîtrise en biologie moléculaire et une
maîtrise dans rampe de l'aude il a le
look et müller le conte est alors
maintenant il est là il était sur le
pont et que je me souviens d'un truc à
vous
la blonde mais tu es blonde la celle que
tu avais prises dans les fonds marins
ah oui ah oui ah oui oh oui je vois je
vois ton estomac mais je vais raconter
ça laisse alors parce que c'était la
petite plante qui s'occupait du stage de
vannerie et alors elle faisait
simplement vont payer ses vacances ici
parce qu'alors elle fait des études
d'agriculture et asseoir vous tu avais
la migraine
elle m'avait emmené dans la palmeraie
faire mûrir les dates oui mais c 'est ça
n'a aucun intérêt
ça n'a aucun intérêt d'autant qu'elle
moi j'ai très envie qu'on chante les
chansons qu'on avait tous les quatre
années de son mandat
vous soutenez lève la main là mais les
bleus prennent le thé avec le pied l'été
les beloteurs tu fais pas tu est ce
qu'on se marre marre de me le coup
mais alors attends attends c'est pas
tout c'est que le garage vais faire je
vais faire allonger oui avec le camion
puisque la boîte et en inde il ouvre
brady tous battus 6-10 ghisi pour mettre
la caravane qu'on a acheté tu te
rappelles les photos des petits car van
de plataan j'avais vu du oui avec le
photon cieux j'avais posé devant wii à
banos 400 places 10e figurez-vous qu'il
a un copain dans les ptt qui a réservé
une place au camping des ptt à mimizan
comme sow et bien vous allez être comme
des princes ce cas vous aussi parce que
vous venez avec nous
ça vous plaît
et en juillet portant yougoslavie est
retourné chez les arabes on a versé les
arts mélanésiens pu tout de rien de 200
à l'heure non vous aimez vous venez non
mais je pense aussi que la place la
place n'est pas réfléchir que la plage
que j'ai elle est à 3 des cabinets trois
places des cabinets avril c'est tentant
de la porte de caravanes à la pop et en
plus c'est juste sous un pont ah oui
dans les langues c'est appréciable
complète pas mourir dans l'ambiance
là-bas la maison il ya deux ans y avait
été alors tout le 14 juillet il ya des
fêtes namdeb savez les vaches landaises
et toi même le roger il était descendu
pour attraper la conca on parlera entre
les sécateurs donc à beaucoup de
corridas
on voit encore les oreilles non sais pas
s'ils respectent
si de rien du tout ne peuvent rien du
tout moi donc tu sais quoi faire
non on va passer la nuit dans la
caravane pour laisser le coup on va même
bien et en chantant